hello and welcome to our Bongo DB
tutorial what we're going to build in
this tutorial is a very simple another
expression deployed on turbo using the
[ __ ] database of course and it's going
to have two models it's going to have a
profile and a team so that's going to
simulate sort of like a like a project
for like a team like there's some sort
of sport or recreational league
something like that we're going to use a
REST API to interface with the data so
we're going to set up a basic REST API
for all the query and sorting data and
things of that sort
we're obviously going to focus on the
MongoDB in terms of topics we're going
to use the Mongoose ORM which is
definitely the most popular ORM for the
JavaScript community for MongoDB and
we're going to cover all the crud
operations for using [ __ ] and mongoose
so crud is create read update and delete
and we will cover all four of those in
this tutorial again using the REST API
this is a beginner tutorial but it's not
for complete beginners you should have a
basic not working knowledge of HTML CSS
and JavaScript as well as how to set up
a node express project the the basics of
node Express should be familiar to you
you don't have to be an expert again
this is a beginner project but you
should know how to set up a node Express
project install NPM modules etc know how
to use the static directory as well as
templating engines and things like that
you will need a turbo account so that we
can deploy our projects that is free and
your we're also going to use the M lab
service for our [ __ ] hosting so you'll
need an account on M lab which is also
free and you can sign up at M lab comm
so make sure you have all that ready to
go and then we can go ahead and dive in
so in this video we're going to get our
tools set up so first thing you want to
be sure about is you want to be sure
that you have node and NPM installed on
your machine so head over to know G org
if you don't and make
you install the VLTs version right here
and you should be all set to go with
node and NPM if you want to if you want
to check beforehand you can do node -
fee and you can see I'm running 8.11 and
then you can do mkm - tree to see what
version of NPM you are running if
neither of these return values for you
just go ahead and install the node
runtime on your computer and you should
be good to go next we're going to need
to install [ __ ] itself which I'm going
to use a homebrew to do that so brew Sh
head over to here and install homebrew
if you don't already have it you can
just copy and paste this into your
terminal and you should have that will
install homebrew homebrew is a package
manager for your machine it installs
well it installs then updates packages
so that's what it does and we're going
to use that for installing [ __ ] so if
you do not have monkey well let's check
if you have [ __ ] so one way you can do
that is by doing [ __ ] - - version and
here I'm running 4.0.1
so if you do not get a return value from
this command that means you need to
install monka so one way you can do that
is brew brew install [ __ ] DB like so
and that will install the [ __ ] database
on your local machine that normally
takes it takes a couple of minutes so
just be patient with that and follow the
commands whenever you get prompted with
further instructions next we will need
the turbo CLI so make sure you have the
turbo CLI installed you can check by
running turbo version and make sure you
have a version number like this or
higher so if you have a previous version
than this that means you need to update
and that's very easy we used to do sudo
NPM I - G and then turbo CLI and this
will install the turbo CLI on your
machine and then I'll give you the
ability to deploy your projects onto the
turbo
staging environment which is also free
so make sure you have that set to go and
once you have all that we should be all
set so we should be ready to start with
our project
and let's go ahead and get started with
our project so
first things first you got to make sure
you have a an account on turbo 360 Co so
head over here so that we can go ahead
and set up our account so that we can
deploy to our staging server this is
free so don't worry about that so once
you have that open up your terminal and
CD change directory to your desktop like
so or wherever you prefer to do your
work I'm going to do it in the desktop
and let's create a new turbo project
let's call it [ __ ] proj and this
creates another Express project a very
basic note Express project so I'm going
to open this up in the text editor I'm
using sublime and here you will see the
app j/s where the project is set up and
we have our standard you know our routes
our views in our public directory the
views are for your templates we're using
our the mustache templating engine
routes we have two routes we have an API
route and an index route these are just
scaffolds it by the the scaffold right
out-of-the-box we can change these as
needed obviously and public is for your
static assets JavaScript images and CSS
so that is all set to go now if you look
at the well let's head over to our
terminal and CD into the [ __ ] proj now
given that this is a node Express
project we have to install our
dependencies as defined in the
package.json these are not yet installed
so make sure you head over to your root
directory and then do NPM install in
order to install those packages and that
usually takes about a minute or so so
while that's going let's head over to
our app j/s where our project is
basically set up and let's step through
this to figure out our configuration so
if you look at line four you will see
that this is where the app is
initialized and this is an express app
it's called vertex here because that's
the vertex Izzie is an Express
application basically configured
modified for the turbo environment so
it's just an express app with a few
minor modifications
so here is the instantiation but if you
look down here on line 24 you'll see
another instantiation which takes a
config object which is defined on line
11 and inside this config object is
where we set up our some configuration
options view static directory and most
importantly DB on line 14 so what we
want to do is we want to use this
instantiation instead so let's get rid
of line for just remove it and then
uncomment this right here and like so
actually we can just get rid of this
whole thing so now we're going to use
the config object to configure our
project and the most important line
right now is this one right here line 8
where we define our database URL so
we're going to comment that out and
replace it with our own database URL
which for now will be an empty string so
what this is going to be is a reference
to our local [ __ ] server so what we
want to do is [ __ ] DB colon slash slash
local host slash [ __ ] proj and this
last term right here will be the name of
our database so this is the pattern for
the default pattern for local [ __ ] URLs
so and again the last one here is the
name of our database which we can name
it whatever we want so here is how we
configure our project to run with a
local [ __ ] server so what we want to do
now is test that so we can do turbo dev
server
and we will see this message here DB
connection failed which is this message
right here the on error callback well
that's because we're not running a local
database so we want to stop the web
server and then do command T to open
another tab and then we want to do [ __ ]
D like that and this will run the local
[ __ ] server and all these lines will
pop up but most importantly is this last
line right here waiting for connections
on port two seven zero one seven this is
the default port number for local [ __ ]
instances so now we're running a [ __ ]
server locally on our machine we can
head back to our web server and run the
dev server again but before we do I'm
gonna include an on success callback so
that we can get a confirmation message
DB connected in order to confirm that
the database was successfully connected
to our web project so let's go ahead and
check that out so we can do turbo dev
server again and there we go the
database had is successfully connecting
and our project is running locally on
localhost 3000 so we can head over to
localhost 3000 in our browser and we can
see our project running locally this is
the how your project should look while
running the database so this is now
database connected to your local [ __ ]
instance so everything is ready to go
our models for our project to work with
which will be profile and team and
that's it so let's go ahead and get
started let's go ahead and head back to
our terminal and run the [ __ ] server so
in a separate tab I'm running the local
[ __ ] server and then in the web server
I'm gonna run trip out dev server and
then head over to localhost 3000 to make
sure everything still works which it
does so everything is still in working
order so I'm going to turn off the web
server make sure you're in the root
directory and we're gonna create a new
folder called models which is where
we're going to store our models models
for profile and team which will define
the schemas for each so we want to head
over to that directory and create a
profile J s and we may as well do the
team one right now as well and then head
back to the root and let's go back to
our models directory and open up the
profile J s and here is where we will
define the schema the attributes which
comprise a profile in our project within
the context of our project so we're
going to need the mongoose ORM so let's
go ahead and import that and then let's
go ahead and create the profile schema
which is a new mongoose schema object
now make sure you insert the JSON
argument here and then let's go ahead
and export it module exports and this is
a mongoose model which we will call
profile which takes the profile schema
that we're about to define so in here is
where all of the action takes place here
is where we define the actual attributes
which comprises a profile so first name
last name email password things like
that all that goes in here so let's go
ahead and get that process started so we
want to start with the first name and
these all take JSON arguments or these
are all JSON values excuse me
last name age team and position okay
great so these are all empty JSON values
but obviously they shouldn't stay empty
so these all of these attributes are
going to be strings except for age age
is going to be a number so we want to
define that in these JSON arguments we
inside these JSON values we define we
determine the datatype of the respective
attribute so all of these are going to
be string the except for the age which
is going to be a number and then
technically we can stop here and this is
a complete schema but we can actually go
we want to take advantage of a few more
options we want to assign default values
to all of these and in the case of all
the strings the default value will be
empty string in the case of the number
it will be zero so the default value
basically gives these attributes an
automatic value if the user doesn't
input one during the process of creating
the profile so when there's data being
sent to our our server if the first name
attribute is undefined the Mongoose
schema will insert an empty string on
our behalf which is a nice tool so so
this is one extra tool we can use that
provided to us by Mongoose to make this
our data more consistent in the [ __ ]
database so another value another tool
we want to use is called trim and this
is a boolean which we will set to true
so what this does is that it removes any
trailing whitespace so for example if we
have a
user named Bob like so Bob during
registration Bob may have done something
like this where he put an empty space
and at the trailing edge by mistake in
all likelihood this is not on purpose so
we want to trim those trailing and as
well as preceding white spaces so that
this doesn't mess up our database
integrity so we definitely want to take
advantage of things like that
so we want to trim the last name as well
team and the position and there are a
series of other options we can include
which we won't get to for now just just
understand that the Mongoose ORM
provides us a series of tools like this
which makes the data more consistent
within our [ __ ] database so that it
sits across all of our records there's
more consistency within the attributes
which is very very very very useful so
now that we have our profile setup
schema set up the question is how can we
query those profiles how can we use this
to to fetch the profiles from our
back-end so what we're going to do is
we're going to use one of the provided
from the scaffold specifically the API
wrap the API route is provided to us
automatically from the scaffold we're
not going to use what's in here so let's
get rid of this and want to create our
own routes instead so what we want to do
is create a get handler which takes a
string argument and we want to call it
profile and this get handler will fetch
all the profiles currently in our [ __ ]
database so this takes a wreck request
and a response object and for now we're
just going to return a JSON response
with a hard-coded
output sometimes these are called end
points and Stan's will just call this
end point so right now that's all it's
going to return right so what we want to
do is we want to test that end point by
heading back to our terminal
running the dev server head over to
localhost 3000 now if you look at the
apt yes you'll see that the routes are
connected on the bottom and you'll see
that the API route is connected in the
path with the path slash API so if we do
slash API and then slash profile that
will invoke this endpoint so we do slash
API slash profile and here we have the
endpoint we just wrote a few minutes ago
so that worked so now what that means is
within this endpoint we can query the
profiles using this schema so let's go
ahead and do that so we do can't we have
to import that of course
okay so now here we have our profile
model which is a mongoose object so we
want to run the find query which returns
a promise and the promise success block
returns the profiles from the database
so we can get rid of this now and this
right here is our first [ __ ] slash
Mongoose query this is going to query
every profile currently in our [ __ ]
database our back-end and return them in
this success block right here so we can
do rest JSON and then confirmation
success you know profiles and that will
return the profiles you know or browser
just like it did over here and before we
finish that there let's handle the error
scenario so this is the catch block
which is the error case so we want to
return an error message here obviously
the confirmation is not successes fail
and then we should return a message from
the error object which should indicate
what went wrong so this query right here
is for every profile in our database for
[ __ ] database so now if we rerun this
this request we should see an empty
array because there are no profiles in
our database so that's that's the
expected outcome because right now we
don't have any profiles so here what
we've done is we've set up a very simple
query for schema that currently is
defined in the models as per this set of
attributes right here and then we
created we ran a request against that
schema but we don't have any data in the
backend so right now we're just getting
empty result set so so far so good but
obviously we want to have some data to
work with next one is setup
database with some initial data what's
often called seed data using some static
JSON objects and that we will insert
those records into our database
so that when we run this query we have
some stuff to work with
and my terminal is right here I'm going
to turn off everything that's running so
we can start from scratch
so first things first let's run the
manga server locally so by doing [ __ ] d
and then head over to your web server
and the turbo dev server and then make
sure that everything still works so here
is the API slash profile route that we
created specifically to fetch profiles
and again there are no profiles so let's
go ahead and turn off our web server and
let's create a JSON file which will we
can use to insert some initial data into
our database so right now we're doing
what's called we're using what's called
CD David we're going to speed the
database with some initial data so that
we have some stuff to work with right
away [ __ ] is a JSON based document
storage database so what that means is
if we just create some JSON records JSON
objects we can insert them directly into
our [ __ ] database using the CLI which
is exactly what we're going to do so
first things first we've got to create
the JSON files by the JSON object so
let's create a directory for this let's
call it initial for initial data
let's CD into the initial folder and
let's create a profile JSON file head
back to your root directory and then
actually no you want let's stay in the
initial ok and then open this up and
let's create our profiles so this this
set of profiles we're about to create
should be consistent with the profile
schema that we defined in the previous
video so first-name lastname age
team position so we have first name
last lasting age position and ting I
believe we have team on there yes notice
how all these are string values except
for the age because that that is defined
as a number in the schema so we have to
be consistent with that over here so now
that we have our first profile we can
just add a few more
all right and let's see actually I'm
going to add one more
okay so here I have four profiles to
start with all JSON objects fitting the
schema as defined in our models
directory so we can insert these records
into our database right away so that we
have some data to work with so let's go
ahead and do that so the way we want to
do that is through the the [ __ ] shell
so we can directly the [ __ ] CLI I
should say we can directly interface
with our [ __ ] database using the CLI so
one way we can do that is by doing [ __ ]
like this just directly connect to our
[ __ ] database make sure your [ __ ]
instance is running otherwise this won't
work and I'm gonna show DBS right and we
can see what our current with what the
current databases are in our database so
we're gonna create a new database
let's do ctrl C and we're going to
insert these records into that database
as a collection so a collection is a
basically it's what it sounds like it's
a collection of records all under one
schema so what we want to do is mom
we're gonna use a tool called [ __ ]
import and it takes a few arguments the
first one is DB and that's going to be
the name of the database if you recall
we set the name in the app J s called
[ __ ] proj so we want to say DB is [ __ ]
proj so that we're going to interface
with the same database and then
collection it's going to be called
profiles it was just basically the
pluralized version of our schema the
profile schema profiles is plural and
then we can we can pass in a file
argument and that's going to be the JSON
file profiles JSON so just so you
understand what's going on here
the Mangal import is going to create
this database [ __ ] prash because right
now it doesn't exist and then afterwards
it's going to create a profiles
collection which will use the profiles
JSON file
for the initial set of data so once I
press enter here is that imported for
documents which are these four documents
right here so it created those four
records in our database so we can head
back to our root directory and run turbo
dev server and now we can test this
endpoint again and now we have our four
full poplars for quarterbacks where
three quarterbacks and one wide receiver
so it worked everything worked one thing
that's very worth pointing out is that
there's this extra field called
underscore ID which we did not define in
here you will not see an underscore ID
in these initial records set that's
because [ __ ] assigns that for us
automatically [ __ ] does that on our
behalf and these are unique identifiers
for each record in the database so this
is a unique number that ties to this
entry in particular it's kind of like a
social security number it only it only
relates to this one record and [ __ ]
does that on our behalf so now that we
have some data to work with we can start
running queries in our API route let's
go ahead and find that right here in our
API route for specific profiles based on
things like you know position position
team things like that or start running
those kinds of queries basically adding
filters to our query so we can get
specific profiles based on parameters
that we with the project may need at a
certain point in time at this juncture
of the video a good exercise would be to
do the same thing for teams you may
remember you may recall we created a
team's model which is empty so we want
to create a similar set up so that would
be a good product good assignment to
work on the team should be
the attributes should be something like
team name City conference so this is
American football we're talking about so
you know team like the New England
Patriots is the the the city is Boston
the name is Patriots the conference is
AFC American Football Conference and
that should be enough for the team
schema so so yeah that's it
let's try to get that put together
here in the terminal
to run the manga local server and the
web server okay
and then if I run a query for all the
profiles we see everything that we added
to our database so now what we want to
do is query the same data with specific
filters so that is done inside here the
API route inside this this find method
from Mongoose inside here we can add a
JSON object that specifies the filters
for example if I say I only want to
query for profiles whose position is QB
I would do it like that and then if I
rerun the query everyone but Odell
Beckham's should be returned see his
position is not QB so here we have three
players all of whom are cubies and then
we can do the same thing for a wide
receiver and now we get only Odell
Beckham who is of course a wide receiver
so the filtering of your queries and
Mongoose is pretty straightforward we
want to make it more dynamic of course
by having the filter coming from the
actual user so what we want is something
like this to return only the cubies so
right here this is the request query we
can parse that out inside the API route
like so so that this req object gives us
the query which is really this key value
pair in JSON form so it's ready in JSON
form for us which is nice so now we can
just insert the query object into the
the fine method from mangu so if I do
this now
I'll give us all the cubies if I do wide
receiver it gives us only the wide
receiver we have in our database which
is one player Odell Beckham
if I want to query by team I can do team
like that and here I have the two
players you know on the Giants of course
I can do the other teams as well whoops
so here is the one player on the
Patriots and if I query team that's not
that doesn't have any players in our
database of course we get an empty array
which is what we expect so that's it
it's good the query filters work so far
we can also query by the numerical value
so here we have three players for
players excuse me ages ranging from 24
to 41 so let's say we want to query for
profiles who are only older than 41 or
we can do exactly 41 like so so this
gives us the one player who's 41 but if
I do 40 then I get nobody
so maybe what I want to do instead is
older than 40 right so the way you would
do that is inside here the way would
look is you query by age and then you
pass in another JSON object and then
inside here you have a special Mongoose
key with the dollar sign that's denoted
by this dollar sign that means it's a
special Mongoose key and the GT stands
for greater than and then you can do 40
right so here now we should only get Tom
Brady who is older than 40 and if I do
30 then I get three players Aaron
Rodgers Eli Manning and Tom Brady and
then I can also add in a less than
filter so query dollar sign LT for less
than and then 40 this will give us the
profiles ages between 30 and 40 and so
that now we should only get these two
players and that gives us Aaron Rodgers
and Eli Manning and so that works and so
it's up to you how you want to structure
this from the actual query itself the
query
a request query itself but for now I'm
just going to use the the greater than
exclusively so one way we can do that is
if we see the age parameter at all if so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a filters object and we are going
to see here if the query contains the
age key so if this age key is is present
inside the request query what we want to
do is take the filters and set the age
as greater than the query age value
and let's see here the best way to do
this would be let's set the filters to
the query to begin with like that and
then we can pass in the filters like so
so by default if the query the request
query has the H key we're querying for
every profile older than the specified
value so right here line 12 we want to
wreck doc query excuse me ting okay and
that should take care of that so now we
get Tom Brady here because he's the only
player older than 40 if I enter 30 I get
everyone older than 30 so forth and so
on if I enter 20 I get everybody so here
I'm just adding a default greater than
if there's an age key passed in that's
only 13 inch capacity and if there's no
H key passed in the filters will be
automatically inserted inserted into the
request basically as is so I can do team
and giants and we still get these two or
we can do position and QB and we only
get the cubies we can do wide receiver
so forth and so on
we're going to query for a specific
record so that we don't have to filter
add filters based on an attribute every
single time we can query for a specific
entry based on the unique identifier so
let's go ahead and get that started now
I'm going to run the [ __ ] local server
and then the web server and then let's
go ahead and set up another end point
for querying a specific entity a
specific profile I should say so let's
go ahead and set up a route or route for
that it's going to be another get and
the path is going to also be profile but
this time I'm going to add a request
parameter called ID and that's going to
be a variable passed into the actual URL
and then the callback for now let's just
have it hard-coded and this ID program
can be parsed out as a program like that
and then we can just return that in the
JSON response for now just to make sure
everything is properly set up so let's
test the endpoint all we have to do here
is do another slash and then some random
text and here you'll see that the data
is returned to us pretty much as is
which is what we're specifying right
here good so it's connected so if you
look at the profiles you'll see that
they all have an ID string that's
randomly generated by [ __ ] and assigned
to the entity by [ __ ] so we can query
specifically by using that ID so what we
want to do is grab the profile and this
time it's find by ID we passing the ID
and that returns a promise again same as
before
and here is the success callback so we
can do confirmation success here
and in the air recall that we want to
handle the error appropriately by
returning a failure confirmation with
the error message so now what we can do
is we can grab so make sure you have
everything here like this we can grab
the profile ID like so and in this case
we have Tom Brady and just append that
to this route and now we get
specifically the request results for Tom
Brady and of course we can test all the
profiles that way so we do Aaron Rodgers
so forth and so on
we can confirm that they all work and
then what we want to do is make sure
that it works in the failure scenario as
well so for example if I do if I enter
an ID that doesn't exist it should
return an error message now this error
message is a little bit hard to decipher
if you're not not a programmer or not
very familiar with sort of the Mongoose
error styles so instead of returning
just the error message we should replace
that with profile ID not found a much
more human readable message so that it's
very quick and easy to see what exactly
what went wrong so I think that would be
a better way to handle that so that when
you when you come across this error it's
immediately obvious what what went wrong
I was just testing something there don't
worry about that so that it's a lot
faster to determine what the proper
adjustments are and that's it and this
is one which is a way to query a
specific record by the identifier which
is a much more efficient type of query
than using this this kind you don't want
to use this general query every single
time because it's not the most efficient
if you can query by a specific key and
ID that's much faster so you want to do
this one whenever it's possible or
whatever it's appropriate you want to
use the identifier to query for a
the cracker
we're gonna create the ability to add
records from the web interface rather
than from the [ __ ] client-side [ __ ]
CLI excuse me so that users can add
profiles when they sign up so that's it
let's go ahead and get started so now
what we want to do is add the ability to
create a profile from the web web
interface so what we want to do is go to
the API or route where we set up our
queries and set up another endpoint
where a user can create a profile
probably through signing up this all
this usually happens through a post
request rather than a get request so
these this is a get request that's a get
request but this time we want to set up
a post request because the adding data
is usually happens from a post request
especially doing one dealing with a REST
API which is essentially what we're
setting up here on a basic level so here
we want to set up a post and point
and then like usual we just want to
return a hard-coded confirmation now the
data in a post request is in a node
Express application is returned to us in
the req body the body attribute of the
request so when the post data is
submitted to the endpoint here is where
the actual data can be retrieved so now
the question is how do we set up the
post request
well that normally happens through a
form on the on a web on a website in
actual HTML web page so if we go to the
home page of this project localhost 3000
here you will see our home page and this
is just regular HTML CSS JavaScript etc
and this page in particular is inside
the fuse directory right here index dot
mustache and mustache is the templating
engine that is installed by default so
we can use this to create a form where a
new profile can be submitted so let's
get rid of all these other all this
other content because we don't need it
anymore so let's get rid of all this
stuff
and here inside the last remaining give
let's set up a forum where we can create
inputs for each of the attributes of the
profile so we have first name oops this
should be the type is text excuse me
text text inputs so we have first name
last name team position and age now
these attributes these name attributes
should correlate to the properties in
the actual schema so they should match
up with what we see here in also in
terms of casing upper case lower case
said that all has to match up so make
sure yours matches up as well and if we
take a look at the home page now we
should see this it's gonna be hard to
know what field corresponds to what so
we can use the placeholder attribute for
that first name
last name team position age now we have
the placeholders makes it easier to
remember what goes with what and the
final input should be a submit type
doesn't need a name but it could use a
value add profile so now we have a
button which will send the request now
now we have a form here that right now
points to nothing so we want to point
the data of this form to this endpoint
so the way you do that is by adding two
attributes in the form itself action and
method now the method is post and that
this post right here is in relation to
that post right there in other words
this is a post request and the action is
slash API slash profile as specified by
this path right here and it's slash API
because it's that's the original path
right there so slash API slash profile
is where this should go this data should
be submitted to and if everything is
properly set up this is the response we
should get basically just it'll just
spit the data right back to us in JSON
form so if I load the homepage and I add
another profile
I think it's one word here we have the
data basically just returned right back
to us in JSON form thereby confirming
that it worked
at this endpoint this endpoint right
here is successfully receiving the data
so now that we've confirmed that we can
now create an entry a profile entry in
the database using the create command
and we can simply take the request body
which is the data in JSON form it's all
of this already in JSON form and run the
standard promise sequence now Mongoose
returns a profile or the object the
document that's created it returns it
back to us in the completion block the
success block so right here we can just
return the success confirmation with the
profile that was just created and then
in here is the error block so we do what
we normally do here we turn a fail
message a failure confirmation with the
error message so that we can see what
went wrong and then we can now get rid
of this and if we go back to the home
page we can try it again
QV now it's going to return the json
Agamben notice this time there's a
version an ID and a version that comes
from [ __ ]
so what that means is the requests are
successful if I actually take the ID and
run the ID request we get Russell Wilson
again and if I run the general profile
request we get all the quarterback all
the players including Russell Wilson the
player would just create it who is a
quarterback so if we do position QB now
we get Russell Wilson as well inside the
results set and so forth and so on so so
we worked so this is the the proper way
to handle inserting data into the
database which almost always happens
through some sort of form of this sort
like like this is a very conventional
way of submitting data from a form to a
post handler like that and then and then
inserting that data into the database
this is the proper way of handling that
situation so hopefully you got that
working at this juncture a good exercise
is to continue this process for the
teams you may have noticed that we
haven't really been doing much work with
the teams because this is something I
want you to do on your own as you go
through this project so you should set
up corresponding endpoints for profile
and teams and as well as post handler so
that you can create a team through a
form on the on the home page in this
fashion
simple way to update the data it'll be
done through a simple get request which
is not the conventional way by the way
we're going to take a little bit of a
shortcut here just to illustrate the
concept as well as the the commands to
create an update and then we'll update
some of our profiles and and that's it
so let's get started
and so let's say we want to update this
right what I'm going to do is set up a
an endpoint just for updating so it's
going to be right here
router this is going to be a get but
normally this is a put the reason I'm
using a get is just to make this process
a little bit more convenient but
normally this would be done through a
put its a profile then that update
actually this should be over here
you may be wondering why I placed the
handler above this one because this one
is a generic
as a generic ID parameter after the
profile path which will be interpreted
first and if I put this one beneath it
it no request will ever actually get to
this endpoint because this one will
reach first if that makes any sense
however by putting this one above the
update command will happen will be
interpreted before this one and so we
can we can process the requests so let's
try sending a hard-coded
hard-coded response and let's see if
that works there we go and if I go back
here this still works fine so we are set
to go okay so what we want is the query
parameters then this should require ID
and key value pairs for what to update
so for example it might be like here's
an ID number for Russell Wilson so the
request would look like this
ID equals that so we're specifying which
profile specifically we want to update
and then let's say we want to update the
team let's say he got trade it's a team
equals Cardinals and this will update
the profile this particular profile the
team value and that's it or maybe he you
know he aged one more he got one year
older or he changed position etc so what
we want to do is grab the ID and then we
want to get the profile and then find by
ID and update and this will take the
profile ID argument and then the query
and then new equals true this last part
is a little tricky what's happening here
is that by default Mongoose will return
the the record prior to the update or in
reality we normally want the record
after the update so by returning by
passing in this true boolean that's what
we get it's a bit of a sneaky gotcha
that you want to keep in mind about
Mongoose and then here we just do what
we normally do
let's get rid of that and the error is
the same as always just return the
failure confirmation with a message and
the success return the updated profile
so here we are grabbing the profile ID
from the query and then we are
identifying the specific profile based
on that whatever else is in the query
parameters we pass in here as the
updates actually I'm going to do one
more thing just to be sure I'm going to
remove the ID so now all that's left are
the parameters that we want to update
like the team the position the age
things like that so and then we return
the new version over here so let's try
it so now when I run this request
it should say team C Cardinals and there
it is now if I run the overall request
head down to Russell Wilson it says
Cardinals let's say Eli Manning let's
insert his ID
while city age is 38 so at some point
I'll turn 38 and there it is and then if
I go back here you'll see that the age
is still 37 if I reload it now should
say 38 so this is a standard update
using [ __ ] and Mongoose again I want to
point out that this is normally handled
through a put request right here put
rather than I get but the reason I set
it up as a get it so that I can run it
through the browser like this for a
convenient way of doing that rather than
sending up a whole web front-end just
for this
however just be aware that this is not
this area right here is non restful very
important
rest full and normally it should be
handled through a report so this is how
you handle updates in [ __ ] and Mongoose
I recommend you set up the same thing
for teams now so that you can update
your teams if I'm not really sure what
what categories are the team will change
sometimes cities teams change cities
fairly frequently so maybe that's
something you might want to test and
that's it
with the sequence the crowd sequence by
deleting a few records and making sure
that that can be handled as well like
before we're going to set that up
through a gap request which normally
wouldn't be the case but for the sake of
convenience I'm going to set it up as
they get requests so we can we can test
it run it through the browser and make
sure everything works so let's go ahead
and get started
here we set up this request right here
before updating I'm going to do one more
after it as another get a profile and
this is gonna be remove to remove a
record a specific record and it's gonna
be the same idea it's gonna take an ID
and in this case that's all it's gonna
need because that's enough to identify
which record we want to remove right so
we want to grab the query object and
then we want to do profile find by ID
and remove that's the Mongoose
corresponding Mongoose query for
removing a profile and then this is
going to return the usual this is just a
promise but this time there is no
profile keep in mind because there what
excuse me the profile has been removed
so what we want to do is handle the
error like I normally do and then here
on the success return a success
confirmation and then just return a
message saying profile query the ID
successfully removed that's good enough
for now and that will confirm that the
removal of this specific record is
complete and successful so let's go
ahead and test it out so it's profile
slash remove and then we have to pass in
the ID into the query so let's say we
want to remove
Aaron Rodgers so we do slash profile and
then don't forget the endpoint is remove
so slash remove and then we pass in an
ID filter and then we paste in the ID
and then profile was successfully
removed so if I do a general profile
request now we should no longer see
Aaron Rodgers and that is that has been
completed so obviously we can continue
testing but oftentimes what happens
during your throughout your testing
process especially locally is that you
end up with all these records that were
just inserted for pure testing purposes
and have all sorts of inconsistent data
patterns and things like that like maybe
you initially had the age of string and
then change your mind later making it a
number so forth and so on things like
that this is very common in a local
testing environment so it's not unusual
at all for it within local testing to
want to remove all of the records the
whole thing the entire the entire
collection would be a way to rephrase
that
so this happens a lot so what what you
want to do here instead of removing
everything one at a time because maybe
you have instead of four or five you
have 50 or 60 so that can be very
tedious to remove everything one at a
time what you'd rather do everything why
you rather do instead is to remove the
entire collection in one command and we
can do that through the CLI I do this a
lot through the CLI so if I open a new
tab I can connect to the database
directly and the name of the database if
you ever forget you just go back to the
app chest and you just look it up right
here in the URL and I can just connect
it directly to the database and so here
I am and then I want to do show
collections to see what I have and
currently have I have profiles and then
I can do DB profiles and then find and
then I can see spell the wrong profiles
I can see what profiles I currently have
in the backend the database which is
obviously the examples we used in the
video so far so I can just draw
the entire collection very easily by
doing instead of fine I can do drop like
that and they should return true if it
was successful so now if I go back to
the API and I run this request I get an
empty array because now we removed all
the profiles in one quick command so
that's another way you can do that by
interfacing directly with the [ __ ] CLI
rather than Mongoose and then we can
when we're done with them just to exit
we're done with that and then now we're
back down to zero so that's it that's
another way of quickly removing a whole
set of collections which again is very
common in a local testing environment
because oftentimes you have all these
records that we're only there for
testing if the data is all messed up and
things are inconsistent and you just
need to sort of wipe your slate clean
and start fresh which is what we just
did right here so that's it that
completes our crud operations for now
there's obviously a lot more that you
can you can look into using the [ __ ]
slash mongoose documentation I highly
recommend you look into the
documentation for mongoose Alissa's damn
p.m. page what we really want is the
documentation page and it'll give you
the entire set of api's that you can use
in the mongoose ORM which extends much
further than what what i've shared so
far but in this series so far we've gone
through the basics which is enough to
get you started and putting together a
very basic application web application
ploy to a staging environment and get
our database working on an actual
database server so we are going to get
that set up today and that's it so let's
get started
you are going to need an account on M
lab right here
so make sure you have that as well as
turbo you should already have that but
if you don't go to turbo 360 Co this is
where we're going to deploy our projects
and we're going to host our application
on here and host our database on here so
make sure you have that properly make
those make sure you have those accounts
properly ready to go so what we want to
do next is head over to our project and
we're going to make a slight adjustment
here so this early on we had commented
out this line right here which is using
environment variables to establish the
database URLs so this one right here
MongoDB URI is your local environment
variable for the database local database
so really what we want to do is we want
to reuse this right here so if we head
over to the env file right here is where
you will see the environment variables
configured for your project so we need
to define the MongoDB URI and that is
going to be our local URL what we've
been using so far so now if we head over
back to App j/s instead of using the
actual string we want to use the
environment variable like so and this is
a better way to handle it so what we can
do now is test it by running the [ __ ]
server and then running the dev server
to make sure everything still works as
expected
and it does so everything is still set
to go we can just run it one quick query
to make sure about that and just confirm
that everything is still working which
it is that's great so we're good to go
on that so now what we want to do next
is set the production you will database
URL and this is the M lab URL so we need
to establish that first so we head over
to M lab and we sign up if you don't
have an account I already do so I'm
going to login and we now want to create
a new database right here so make sure
you click on that you can choose any of
these three I want to use Amazon because
that's my preferred provider I'm going
to we want to create the sandbox account
because it's free I'm gonna use a u.s.
used one it doesn't really matter but
I'm in the East Coast so I'm going to
use US East one database name so [ __ ]
Farraj it's good enough turbo [ __ ]
approach doesn't really matter but this
will help me keep track great and here
are some just configuration options etc
and then we go ahead and create the
database and this is going to create the
database for you right here and we can
click on that now and we need to create
a database user which we can just call
admin for now so we the user without we
create needs a username and a password
so we add a database user will call it
admin and password will just say is
turbo 360 obviously you can make these
wherever you want
and in doing so we now have our
production URL string right here so you
copy that
and then you head back over to your
project and then you enter you paste
that in but make sure you have your user
and your password so the user
well the password is turbo 360 and the
user is admin and so now we have our
production database URL right here and
that's ready to go
so now we can head back to our app j/s
then really we can just uncomment the
original URL line and remove this and so
what this establishes is that if the
environment is the dev environment or
the local environment it will use the
local database URL otherwise it will use
the production database URL so it's
important to understand here is that the
turbo environment is right now dev
inside the env
variables env file but when you deploy
the project to your turbo staging server
it will automatically switch to
production so you don't have to change
this in fact you know you really never
should change this so now what we need
to do is set it up so that we can deploy
our project to turbo
so we have our M lab configuration all
set that's done we're ready to go with
that so now what you want to do is head
over to turbo and sign up over here
which is free or you can sign up on the
right side if you don't have if you
don't see this and then log into your
account and then in your projects
you want to create a new project here
called [ __ ] project or [ __ ] demo
whatever you don't need a description
though just go ahead and create it and
click the Create site I'm not going to
do that because I already have a project
set up for this and when you do that you
should see this interface
and what we need right now is the app ID
this is what we use to connect our local
project to our staging server on turbo
so you head back to your terminal you
turn off the local server and the first
thing you need to do is log in to turbo
like so and just log in using the
account that you use to set up just now
and then you want to do turbo app and
then you paste in your app ID from here
just copy and paste it right there like
that and this command will connect your
local project to your staging
environment on turbo it's really that
simple and then once that's connected
you're all set to go you do turbo deploy
and they will deploy the project to your
staging environment on turbo which
usually takes around a minute and when
it's done it will give you a staging URL
you know a web-based URL that's a live
web URL that you can hit on your browser
and check out your project
so mine is wrapping up just now and when
it's done right here you get that deploy
complete message and this is your
staging URL right here then that is
where your project is hosted that huge
copy and paste that into your browser
you should get a you should get the
interface that we had last time locally
but now it's on our browser so before we
test anything let's copy that over into
another tab and do API profile and see
if we get any kind of response which we
do and that's because it is currently
connected to our M lab account right
here and if we click on the home we will
see that we have our turbo [ __ ] progr I
here of course it's empty there's
nothing in here right so what we can do
next is head back to our home page and
add our first record in our production
database or at least our staging
database so let's see here whoever not
gotten to yet Matt Ryan Falcons
quarterback 32 so let's see what happens
here so here on production we get the
JSON values for the entry we just added
with the [ __ ] entry so that's a good ID
excuse me
so if we head over to the EM lab page
you will see if we reload the EM lab you
will see the profiles has one document
and that corresponds to the entry I just
inserted and more importantly if we head
over to our API slash profile page
sorry that's localhost if we head over
to our API slash profile endpoint we now
see matt ryan the quarterback who we
just entered into our production
database we can now grab the ID and then
do a back slash ID and we get the same
person it's only one anyway we can test
all the filters so position equals
quarterback and we still get that Ryan
because that's the only one if we try a
wide receiver we get empty array so
that's good we can do
profile update ID perhaps I got the age
wrong
I don't really know his age so I'm just
guessing so maybe it's and then age
maybe he's 31
and then 31 and there we go and
everything we set up before now
currently works on our staging
environment just like we saw on local so
everything is successful on staging as
on local which obviously is very very
important and and that's it so if you
got all this working congratulations you
have a nerd Express application with a M
[ __ ] database connected and
successfully reading and writing data to
your database so that's clearly a big
step towards your development as a full
stack engineer and hopefully you got
everything working if you have any
questions comments anything like that
feel free to shoot me an email you can
reach me at the Kuan at turbo 360 CO
that's my email and I'll get back to you
soon as I can and and yeah that's it
thanks again for watching and best of
luck in your future endeavors